[Music]
all right well there's been a lot of
talk recently about changes to the HOV
lanes on our freeways traffic anchored
Nate Tanenbaum is here to straighten it
all out in today's what's driving you
crazy
[Music]
yeah there are new rules now in place
when it comes to those HOV lanes in Las
Vegas and there's a twist
the Nevada Department of Transportation
has been updating freeway signs to show
that HOV lanes are no longer enforced 24
7. Justin Hopkins with the new rule two
passengers or more in the HOV lanes
between the hours of 5 a.m and 10 p.m 7
days a week and then after 10 pm and
before 5 a.m those lanes are open to all
drivers so anybody can use those Lanes
but there's already an exception to the
new rule and we mentioned it on the air
the other day here it is on the overhead
side the HOV open to everyone between
Spring Mountain all the way down to
Silverado Ranch that's the general area
of indot's huge I-15 Tropicana rebuild
it's going to kick into high gear in
January because of driver confusion
about that free HOV lanes Hopkins says
what we decided to do was make the
availability of the HOV lanes much
longer and we're going to do some
restriping that double white line will
be gone for that entire stretch that'll
all be done by before Thanksgiving
and Hopkins has some great information
about how ndot knows how many people are
or aren't in cars using HOV lanes we'll
talk about that in our next Revenue
crazy report buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone and join the
driving you crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com